your presence is requested at the Royal  Wedding of Prince gisbert of Bend  and Princess B do you take this man to  be your husband no oh my god this is a  bad time to be coming down off of that  hi so how'd it go  I want to be in charge of my own destiny  I want to see the outside world  I wanted it rid of all the diseases  plaguing mankind and replace them with  worse once control I don't even know  what they yell at you I'm not so bad  well you did kill that one guy I'd be  fine if someone could just slide my head  up a bit  isn't there a queen everyone's life  where they need to go and figure out who  they are  well I'm a good butcher this is a pet  shop  what's this blowing I don't want to  drink away that's hope  I'm so proud of you I'm elf Oh remember  the trick to not getting swept over the  waterfall is swimming upstream got it  you can do anything if you believe in  yourself  [Music]  you